la parole est à Madame Dominique Verrien
pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre je tiens tout d'abord à vous
dire que j'apprécie particulièrement les
développements de votre rapport annexé à
l'article 1 car nous demandons beaucoup
à nos policiers et à nos gendarmes mais
ils ont besoin de soutien et
d'accompagnement et dans ce rapport nous
trouvons tout ce dont nous rêvons pour
un meilleur fonctionnement de la police
de la gendarmerie et la meilleure prise
en charge des victimes
mes pardonnez-moi je ne suis pas sûr que
tout soit applicable sans avoir recours
à des modifications de la loi
modification que l'on ne trouve pas
forcément dans le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui je pense par
exemple aux évolutions nécessaires pour
assurer notre sécurité lors des grands
événements sportifs à venir ce n'est pas
grave l'intention est louable et cela
nous donnera l'occasion de nous revoir
prochainement revenons donc au texte sur
la police judiciaire d'abord un syndicat
bien connu communique souvent en disant
que le problème de la police c'est la
justice
mais c'est oublier que parfois le
problème de la justice c'est la police
et je n'incriminerai bien sûr pas les
policiers mais force est de constater
que la filière d'investigation n'attire
plus autant qu'avant et ses difficultés
de recrutement avec de nombreuses
équipes en sous-effectif on des
conséquences directes sur la qualité des
enquêtes et le délai de mise en œuvre de
la réponse pénale et les stocks qui se
constituent dans les commissariats sont
autant d'affaires non traitées donc de
justice non rendu qui vont se terminer
trop souvent en déclaration sans suite
faute d'avoir les moyens de les
poursuivre laissant un sentiment
d'injustice au plaignant mais est-ce un
sentiment
en réponse ce texte prévoit une
facilitation de l'exercice des missions
d'investigation un renforcement de
l'efficacité de leur action une
formation initiale plus orientée vers
les métiers de l'investigation ainsi que
la création d'agents de police
judiciaires je salue également la
proposition de nos rapports Loïc et
Hervé et Marc Philippe daubrais
d'attribuer la qualité d'agents de
police judiciaire aux élèves officiers
de la Gendarmerie nationale durant
lorsque l'arrêté afin qu'ils puissent
constituer un renfort appréciable durant
leur stage en unité territoriale
ces apports devraient outre permettre à
plus de dossiers d'être traités de mieux
accompagner les victimes mais attention
à certaines propositions du rapport
annexé car permettre à chacun et chacune
de déposer une plainte et d'en effectuer
le suivi en ligne avec un contact direct
par chat avec un policier ou un gendarme
ce sont de formidables idées mais est-ce
bien réaliste tant ces propositions
représentent un bon de géant par rapport
à la situation actuelle et je crains
quelques déceptions j'espère cependant
me tromper sur le cas particulier des
violences intra-familiales qui sont
devenus un contentieux de masse avec la
libération de la parole le rapport
prévoit un doublement du nombre
d'enquêteurs dédiés et le financement de
200 postes d'intervenants sociaux en
police et en gendarmerie
ces intervenants sociaux sont très
utiles et il est vrai que leur
financement posait trop souvent un
problème que vous proposez donc de
régler je salue aussi la création d'un
fichier de prévention des violences
intrafamilales afin de mesurer pour un
jour empêcher la réitération de faits de
violence et de prendre en compte les
signaux de dangerosité là aussi son
efficacité dépendra de la formation des
forces de l'ordre et de leur capacité à
distinguer les signaux faibles et
apprendre les bonnes décisions
rapidement un gendarme ne doit plus
hésiter à demander le retrait d'une arme
à feu d'un ami chasseur dans un contexte
de violence intrafamiliale
enfin les associations pourront
accompagner plus efficacement les femmes
victimes de violence en organisant le
dépôt de plainte dans leur locaux et en
signalant les faits dont elles ont
connaissance aux forces de l'ordre
j'imagine que ce dépôt de plainte se
fera par déplacement d'un officier ou
d'un agent de police judiciaire d'où
l'utilité de la création de ces derniers
toutes ces mesures vont dans le bon sens
et sont les bienvenus si elles sont
réellement appliquées je ne manquerai
pas de faire un suivi particulièrement
attentif de la mise en oeuvre de ces
mesures après avoir fait un état des
lieux dans le cadre de la mission que
m'a fait confié la première ministre sur
le sujet des violences intrafamiliales
sur le numérique enfin j'ai eu souvent
l'occasion de me pencher sur la
situation du numérique pour la justice
bien moins pour la police mais
heureusement je ne suis pas dépaysée
tant les problèmes sont similaires
d'ailleurs justice et police ont tout
intérêts à travailler et à concevoir
ensemble les outils transversaux
Cassiopée par exemple qui pénalise tant
de magistrats tant magistrat que
policier et gendarmes dans le cadre de
la procédure pénale numérique est un bon
exemple de cette nécessité d'un travail
concerté l'idée d'une grande agence du
numérique pour le ministère de
l'intérieur avec une double tête
gendarmerie police paraît donc
pertinente mais seulement si les leçons
de l'échec du projet scribe en partie dû
à une divergence de vision sur le
numérique entre police et gendarmerie
ont bien été tirés
enfin cela ne relève pas de la loi mais
peut-être faudrait-il aussi se
concentrer sur le plus urgent et sur ce
qui peut être réglé rapidement par
exemple certaines gendarmerie au hasard
dans l'Yonne ne sont toujours pas fibrés
et ne le seront pas avant dans le
meilleur des cas 2023 il est sans doute
possible d'accélérer les choses
hasard toujours je vous alerter sur ce
sujet par une récente question écrite
restez sans réponse à ce jour cet
exemple va un souligner l'importance du
maillage territorial maillage que vous
venez renforcer avec les nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie et les gendarmes
mobiles mieux équipés en plus grand
nombre ainsi que par le développement
des maisons France service
sur ce sujet d'ailleurs monsieur Emilie
monsieur le ministre ça me fait toujours
tiquer quand j'entends vos services
parler de création de maison France
services alors oui c'est bien une
création de nom oui mais j'entends
beaucoup notre préfet notamment par les
créations alors qu'en fait c'est souvent
une montée en compétence c'est vrai mais
de structures de maison de service au
public déjà existantes je pense qu'il y
a suffisamment à faire et que vous en
faites déjà beaucoup pour ne pas gommer
ce que vos prédécesseurs ont pu déjà
créer je dis d'autant plus facilement
que ça n'était pas ma famille politique
mais saluons que les maisons de services
au public existaient déjà en définitive
ce texte enrichi par le travail de nos
rapporteurs que je tiens à saluer de
nouvelles fois constitue une bonne
réponse aux problématiques que nous
connaissons sous réserve de sa juste
application mais vous pouvez compter
monsieur le ministre sur la vigilance du
Sénat à ce sujet en conséquence le
groupe Union centriste votera ce texte
merci